l'abbé pierre vous êtes chercheur
associé à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen orient
merci d'être avec nous l'union
européenne qui menace
ankara de sanctions s'il n'y a pas de
progrès dans le dialogue avec la turquie
avec la grèce plus tôt c'est une demande
d'ailleurs même de d'athènes une liste
de nouvelles mesures restrictives
seraient discutées au sommet de l'union
européenne le 24 septembre de quoi
pourrait-il s'agir
je pense que dans un premier temps voilà
tout le monde essaye d'avoir le maximum
d'arguments pour aller à la table de
négociation à une tension supérieure
d'ordre de militaires comme vous l'avez
signalé est fort peu probable donc il
s'agit pour tous les partis et la
turquie en particulier a donc d'avoir le
maximum d'éléments dans ce jeu il faut
dire que avec l'arrivée des découvertes
de gaz et potentiellement aussi de
pétrole dans la région depuis quelques
années a redistribué les cartes dans la
mesure où avant il n'y avait que des
histoires de pêche donc peu d'intérêt et
d'enjeux économiques
maintenant il y à des milliards de
dollars et quand il ya des milliards de
dollars et surtout autour de l'énergie
eh bien chacun essaye d'avoir la
mainmise ou une part de ce gâteau comme
l'on dit d'autant plus que la géographie
et la politique ont joué à un petit coup
à la turquie puisque des îles grecques
sont à quelques kilomètres du continent
et de la côte turque
donc pour arriver en position de
négociation favorable vis-à-vis de ses
ressources à la turquie des avantages et
dans cet aspect géographique est obligé
de jouer des coudes
oui ce sont pour les manoeuvres
militaires ça derniers jours dans la
zone les enjeux de manoeuvres militaires
mais s'agissant des menaces de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui qui menacent
justement de sanctionner à ankara quel
type de chambre - faut-il s'attendre à
des sanctions de type économique
potentiellement on sait que la situation
économique turque est particulièrement
difficile la turquie a vu sa monnaie
fondre de plusieurs dizaines de pour
cent depuis quelques temps à lille il ya
un taux de chômage élevé
le tourisme habituel ressources
importantes du pays et bien sûr a eu
égard à la situation sanitaire dans une
position difficile donc tout à décisions
économiques à l'encontre de la turquie
serait bien sûr quelque chose de négatif
mais je pense humblement qu'il s'agit
surtout de menaces de façon à éviter une
escalade
en tout cas militaire mais aussi une
escalade diplomatique alors autre
problématique c'est la turquie et la
grèce sont membres on rappelle de l'otan
ont quel rôle peut jouer l'organisation
atlantiste justement dans cette crise
comment on l'a vécu déjà lors de la
tension entre ankara et washington au
sujet des missiles russes s 400 que la
turquie a décidé d'acheter et donc elle
a commencé à les recevoir la réponse
américaine a été de dire nous avons
toujours à d'excellents rapports avec
l'armée turque et la turquie est un
membre important de l'otan donc il faut
savoir il faut se rappeler avec
l'histoire que la sûreté est rentré dans
l'otan n'est ce pas en 1953 quatre ans
avec avant quatre ans avant l'allemagne
dit de l'ouest à l'époque donc
l'histoire est ancienne
les liens géopolitiques sont anciens
donc il ira certainement pas de tension
maximale mais il peut y avoir bien sûr à
des tensions minimale des bateaux qui
s'approche et qui ont eu quelques
impacts il ya quelques jours entre un
bâtiment militaire grec il ya un
bâtiment militaire turc donc on peut
avoir ce genre de tension mais pas de
développement à mon sens on pression de
des européens peut-être pression aussi
des états unis alors il y à déjà le
contentieux dont on vient de parler avec
les s 400 les etats-unis ont quand même
répliquer bien sûr d'un point de vue
économique comme on signalait a déjà
pour les réponses possibles de l'europe
à savoir la noue
livraisons d'avions militaires f 35 mais
surtout le fait que ankara ne pourra pas
participer à la fabrication des pièces
pour cet avion qui est un avion à
vocation mondiale à plusieurs milliers
d'exemplaires vont être vendus et
utilisés dans le monde à paramé
américaine et l'ensemble des alliés des
etats unis
donc c'est à peu près 10 milliards de
dollars d'exportations de pièces pour
cet avion que la turquie ne pourra dont
la taupe qui ne pourra pas bénéficier
donc on a toujours ce jeu compliqué
entre le le militaire elle jeu politique
et l'économique
on voit que les tensions elles sont
fortes depuis quelques jours notamment
depuis cet accord conclu entre la grèce
et les gîtes sur l'exploitation de zones
maritimes dans la région riche en
hydrocarbures
comment voyez vous la suite de ces
tensions est ce qu'elles peuvent
s'aggraver
je ne crois pas je pense qu'on ira de
toute façon à autour du tapis vert
parce que les intérêts sont trop
imbriquées d'espacil y accomplir on
retarde d'autant l'exploitation de ses
richesses
or ces richesses tout le monde en a
besoin larry la turquie est très démuni
en ressources énergétiques
donc elle est impatiente de pouvoir les
exploiter elle vient de dire qu'elle
avait fait une découverte donc de
l'autre côté de ses côtes en mer noire
donc il ya vraiment navy a un appétit
turc d'avancer vers l'industrialisation
de ses ressources et donc pour qu'il y
ait un industriel sion et bien il faut
qu'il y ait une pacification des
relations
merci à vous gérerez père je rappelle
que vous êtes chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen orient